hey everyone how's it going and happy
new year
my name is mayuko and welcome back to my
channel where we talk about tech
career and life so it is finally 2021
and what better way to start off the
year on my channel than with an
intentions video in previous years i've
done like a last year reflections and
this year aspirations video
but 2020 was like a year
obviously events and themes from last
year are gonna come up because we're
always building upon the previous year
but i just kind of wanted to talk about
intentions today
and specifically i want to talk about
intentions not goals because
goals just makes me like feel a little
bit more stressed out like i either
achieved them or i didn't versus
intentions is like i'm orienting myself
towards a certain direction
i don't really know where i'm gonna end
up but these are kind of themes that i'm
going to
play into my year and we'll see how
things turn out
and quickly before we get started i
wanted to say thank you to the sponsor
of today's video
book of the month i know that a lot of
us have aspirations for
books that we want to read this year and
so i think book of the month is a great
service to do so
book of the month is a super popular
fast growing online book service for
readers
i've actually been subscribed to book of
the month previously and so i'm really
excited to be working with them their
whole mission is to promote
new and emerging authors and help
readers discover what books they love
their team vets hundreds of books each
month and gives readers their choice
from a curated selection of new
and early release titles so you can
spend more time reading and less time
researching
book of the month is also risk free so
you can skip any month
anytime and you will not be charged and
one of the biggest perks is that they
have the best price for new hardcover
fiction for january out of the five
books that they have
i chose the dating plan by sarah desai i
chose this one and i'm really excited to
read it because it's a love story about
a software engineer and i was like
it's me this one's for me so you can get
your very first book for just 9.99 by
using the code new books or by clicking
the link in the description box down
below
thank you again and book of the month
for sponsoring today's video and now
let's get back into it
so my intentions for 2021 is generally
to
number one level up and number two to
get to know myself better and ground
myself
this is like day six of 2021 by the way
and it's still kind of formulating in my
brain but that's kind of where i'm
headed towards at least
so as far as leveling up goes 2020 was
an interesting year for me
in that i feel like i've learned so many
new skills
and some of that was necessitated by
covid like
learning how to cut hair or learning how
to make bread
or getting better at cooking other
skills were related to my big career
change so
everything to do with the video stuff
and managing a business
and doing full-time youtube that was
also a ton of skills learned in the last
year
last year was a big year for me in my
anxiety after i had a really bad panic
attack at the end of 2019
and so i've been able to work on these
coping skills that i learned from my
therapist and have built a really good
foundation for how to cope with my
anxiety
and then some things i just like went
for it because they just became my new
hobby so i learned how to do woodworking
last year which was totally unexpected
and had no purpose at all other than i
just wanted to make something with my
hands
and that includes like building and
sanding and refinishing and also
sometimes upholstering things
but really i'm just surprised by like
how many things i was able to learn last
year and i think that's because in
previous years i used to think i
should be doing something or i should be
learning something
but last year i kind of just like let go
of that you know because 2020 was
absolutely wild and i was dealing with
my anxiety where i was afraid of
everything
and so a lot of the things that i did
was out of me wanting to do things or
realizing that i could do these things
like for the first time i feel like i
was just like bold or maybe just didn't
care
that much to overthink all the things
that i wanted to do
and i just did them i don't know if i'm
making sense but i feel like in previous
years i used to just like obsess over
like maybe i could be doing this
or i should be doing that or like oh my
god i should be somewhere by now but
it's
i just never did it because i think i
was too scared to i don't know maybe
it's like a late 20s thing where i just
started to gain more confidence
and just feel like more at peace with
myself and it wasn't confidence in like
a
oh my gosh i'm like the best at
everything and instead it was like a
you know i don't know anything i don't
know how to do this at all but
with time i could probably figure it out
i think a big part of it that was
probably my therapist
yeah doing weekly therapy was incredibly
helpful in 2020. so yeah in 2020 like
obviously there was a lot of change
happening i moved i changed jobs
but really i feel like kind of a
different person like i feel like the
biggest
change was within so last year really
was just kind of like
lots of new beginnings and building a
really strong foundation
so this year is all about leveling all
those things up
i think like i really want to get better
at woodworking i want to read a book
every month i want to work out more
consistently
i want to make the perfect cup of coffee
and i think related to
having this strong foundation of feeling
at peace with myself
is this whole getting to know myself
better and
grounding myself even further i was
watching my 2020 aspirations video and a
lot of it was
around just like grounding myself and
feeling calm and
peace making sure that i practice
grounding myself
and finding home within myself and i
think i did a pretty good job of that
and i just want to keep building on that
because you know the world is a
turbulent place and it feels like it's
only
in some ways gonna get more turbulent so
finding a place
where i can feel peace within feels like
it's gonna be pretty important and by
getting to know myself i don't mean just
like
looking deep within myself and
psychoanalyzing my history and
experiences that i've had but it's also
about like
looking forward to me like i don't
really know what like my next
step or goal or dream is i guess like
for the first time i have
the space and capacity and like empty
blank line to do that and that's
something that i want to figure out this
year and i think in previous years i was
just like too
afraid to like acknowledge that there
was a blank line
after the thing that i had already
defined and so
it used to just like fill me with
anxiety and being like oh my gosh but i
don't know where i'm headed but this
year i feel like
it's like yeah i don't know where i'm
headed and that's fine because i'm going
to enjoy the journey and i think this is
like the logical next step
after going full-time content creator
last year because i finally like
climbed the mountain that i've been
always wanting to climb and now i'm at
the top
i can see all the other mountains around
me for the first time so yeah i don't
really know which direction i want to
head towards but
i want to figure out what feels right to
me like this is me
paving my own path for the first time
without really having any answers
and taking inspiration from lots of
different people and
i just want to figure that out this year
i guess
and i think the grounding part in the
process is really important because
that's how i'm going to stay
true to myself and make sure that the
path that i want to go on is one that
feels authentically me and it's
something that i truly want to do
but who knows what 2021 has in store for
us
i think for the first time in many
months there are glimmers of hope that
we can see on the horizon which
is really kind of like feels like
there's sunshine on our faces or we see
the light at the end of the tunnel here
so i'm feeling pretty good about it i'm
excited
and let's do this thing if you have any
2021
goals aspirations intentions that you've
identified or you're working to identify
then leave them in the comments down
below i'd love to hear from you and as
always don't forget to like this video
and subscribe
i've got a lot of videos and a lot of
plans for this year which
definitely are still works in progress
but i'm really excited about the year to
come and i hope you'll join me in the
journey
i sincerely hope you all are doing well
and staying safe and i will see you next
time
bye